Speaker 1: The second woman. Who was urged
by Herschel Walker to get an abortion, has
now come forward to explain that Herschel Walker
threatened suicide after impregnating her. Now,
it's so hard to keep track of this. You might
remember there was the first woman who said,
Herschel Walker urged me to have an abortion
and I got it. And then he urged me to have
another abortion and I refused. And then
we had a kid. That's woman number one.
Then we had woman number two represented by
attorney Gloria Allred. Woman Number two said,
He urged me to have an abortion and
I did it. I believe that this woman
that we are talking about today is woman number
two, although the reporting is a little unclear
and this may be a third woman, but I'm pretty
sure it's that second woman. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: Ten 9393, she learned
that Mr. Walker had impregnated her.
My client did not want to have an abortion.
When she told Mr. Walker about the pregnancy.
He spoke about disappearing and the, quote,
afterlife, unquote, and made her believe
that he might commit suicide.
Speaker 1: Can you imagine
this level of manipulation?
Speaker 2: He also claimed that
if she gave birth, both our client and
their child would be in danger. Jane Doe
stated that she felt pressured by Mr. Walker's
threats and went alone to the abortion clinic
to have the procedure. But she left crying
because she did not want to go through with it.
After she told Mr. Walker that she did not have
the abortion. She stated that the next day Mr.
Walker drove her in his car to the abortion
clinic to ensure that she had the abortion
that she did not want to have.
Speaker 1: Boston. I'm sure there
are more details to all of these stories and also
stories we haven't heard. At the end of the day,
there are many reasons not to vote for Herschel
Walker. His extreme personal hypocrisy on a lot
of these political issues is one reason his
complete lack of morals is another reason.
His inability to explain what his policies
would be is another reason. His lack of
understanding of policy is another reason, and
also the fact that Raphael Warnock is a pretty
damn good senator. There is already someone
doing that job who is doing a pretty good job.
Everyone must vote on December six or during early
voting. If you live in Georgia, we will be live
with those results. And just the situation
gets more disgusting just about every day.